hey what's up mkbhd here and this laptop
is kind of trying to be
three things at once
kinda
[Music]
so this is the surface laptop studio
it's the studio version of the surface
laptop or the laptop version of the
surface studio
i mean it's both either way it's an
interesting idea it's not completely
unique but it is kind of curious now to
see this in microsoft's own
surface lineup um we've been so busy
with so many other reviews that this is
the first time i'm really getting to
check it out but here we are so the idea
is you have three different modes with
this form factor you have the standard
laptop setup then you have the halfway
folded down easel setup where you're
covering the keyboard but you still have
the trackpad and the touchscreen it's
called stage mode
and then you have a completely folded
flat tablet setup all in one device i
guess it's like a three in one so the
idea is like
pretty cool i but every time i see
something like this my first thought is
always okay
what do you
what do you use each mode for so of
course the laptop mode that's the most
familiar right it's the surface laptop
studio for a reason it's perfectly
capable of that you've got a 3x2 aspect
ratio like other surface devices which
is really nice for taller applications
and multitasking in windows 11 here and
then when you pull the laptop towards
you and want to put it in this sort of
easel position you sort of pop the
bottom of the laptop out from the
magnets and then it naturally sort of
wants to land on some more magnets in
this
45 degree
position
in this easel stand mode it's the only
angle that you can set it up at now this
is this always happens whenever i go
well who would want to use a something
like this i mean it's cool that it can
do it but who would use it like this and
then everyone who does use it like this
comes out of the woodwork and loves to
explain exactly how but i'm just going
to say from my own use of laptops
there's only a couple
reasons i would want a laptop to be
folded over covering the keyboard but
still having the trackpad like this so
it is a touch screen and of course you
still have access to the trackpad but
yeah the way it's sitting kind of
reminds me of an ipad in a folio case
this is fine for watching videos or
watching movies also gaming with a
controller which i've seen a lot of in
their ads with this guy
and any touch first apps now there are
android apps coming to windows 11 and
those don't work as of yet but they
should be in an update soon
but if you do have touch first apps
they'll work here the screen also
definitely wobbles a lot less and feels
much more sturdy at this sort of
anchored angle as you touch the display
with your finger but also yeah there
aren't that many touch first apps that i
use and i'll get more to the app
situation in a second anyway lastly you
can just pop it open and fold it
completely flat and
it's a tablet you know it's not
necessarily as fun to hold and use like
an ipad or even a surface pro but when
it's totally flat
there's your tablet this would be your
full-time touch screen interaction and
where a lot of your use of the new
surface slim pen 2 would come into play
it doesn't sit totally flat but from
what i hear a lot of artists would like
it to be slightly propped up because
it's easier to sketch on like that so
the idea
i really like i think it's pretty cool
you could even maybe get away with
watching a video not at perfectly 45
degrees if you wanted to
um but yeah you might have heard of like
the
acer concept d or the hp elite folio
this is more of like the surface refined
version of those ideas
but even at that
i've noticed this version does have some
weird build quality issues so of course
when this thing is in full-on laptop
mode the screen portion is a bit thicker
than a normal laptop it's way better
than previous surfaces where the whole
computer is up top but you can see it's
still thicker than a normal single
screen because it's two layers instead
of one for the hinge mechanics and
that's fine you barely ever have to look
at that but the air gap around the
outside of this display i noticed is
very inconsistent like i can see little
gaps all the way around the screen that
i just like wanted to squeeze shut i
thought that was really odd
but the rest of the hardware is pretty
solid it's the magnesium and aluminum
casing that's very rigid and if we're
being kind of honest it looks a bit like
a double decker macbook pro type thing
so the silver is the only color and it's
got this top level which is pretty slim
and it's the full width all the way
around and has all the ports then the
bottom piece here is a smaller inset but
it obviously gives it much more internal
volume so when it's just sitting on a
desk it kind of gives this illusion of a
thinner laptop that's kind of hovering
slightly off your desk depending on your
lighting honestly i don't mind it i do
hate the
ports layout though on this thing for
all the positioning as like a
creator-focused laptop and something
creative professionals we use
it's like a macbook pro like
every creative professional i know
i think all of them
use an sd card for something at some
point
no sd card reader on this laptop and
then there's only two usbc ports on the
side here with the surface connect port
and headphone jack on the other side
now i'm happy to see that those two
usb-c ports are thunderbolt 4. that's
awesome for data transfer so my sd card
reader dongle will be fast as ever but
that leaves one port left for a mouse or
any accessory i might use not amazing
but the rest of the design fundamentals
are definitely here uh especially with
just the hardware it's very rigid even
the keyboard itself is pretty nice so
it's just a tiny bit of board flex but
the keys themselves are very clicky and
well laid out i haven't gotten a chance
to test the battery yet since i haven't
had it for long enough but i have
noticed the trackpad is really nice this
is something i was hoping to see more of
with windows 11 and more well optimized
surface devices and i am very impressed
with the trackpad's responsiveness and
the haptic feedback it's honestly it's
on macbook level for me it's reached
that level which is especially helped by
the fact that the display is also 120
hertz love that even the webcam is
pretty good it's only 2 megapixels but
it's 1080p so i guess i'm only saying
this because of how low the standards
have been set but hey it's really quite
decent with colors and exposure i will
say though the one letdown was
definitely the speakers
not a whole lot of room to have great
speakers in this anyway but there's no
grills anywhere it sounds to me like the
sound is coming from the keyboard and
like from the side vents either way
there's almost no bass if you care about
good speakers on a laptop this ain't it
but anyway microsoft has
this laptop starting at
15.99
and that's
kind of where it starts to fall apart a
little bit because first of all i don't
think you'd ever want this spec without
the dedicated gpu so that means you're
looking at at least 2100
and that'll get you the core i7 16 gigs
of ram half a terabyte of ssd and the
nvidia geforce rtx 3050 ti and again
haven't had it for very long haven't
even run any benchmarks but we know
that's
a decently capable cpu and gpu but
in the amd world there's stuff
dramatically outperforming this
and even the gpu is not super powerful
the one up side is if you do want to go
the external gpu route which some people
do with their laptop you do have
thunderbolt 4. but yeah this doesn't
have the highest end specs in the world
so
one of my favorite surfaces ever was a
surface laptop 3 the matte black version
and
whenever i would consider using like a
surface book or something else that
would sort of convert into a two-in-one
the question was always okay am i going
to use
the tablet version am i going to use the
laptop version is it worth getting
something slightly worse at each to have
both so then this surface laptop studio
has a slightly different proposition
which is in the name you've probably
heard about the surface studio by now
the all-in-one desktop pc that tilts
down dramatically into this easel
position for all kinds of pen art and
drafting and things like that so this
laptop brings that third form factor on
the go but unlike the desktop tilting it
down like this immediately covers the
keyboard which probably makes the new
slim pen 2 a pretty mandatory accessory
if you're going to get one of these now
again if you know me i'm not the
greatest artist in the world i'll admit
but i can still appreciate a good
responsive pen and while this definitely
isn't apple pencil levels of responsive
it is very usable and it adds some
interesting features like a small
vibration motor in the pen to simulate
the feeling of writing on actual paper
which
i don't know if it feels exactly like
paper so much as i can feel the pen
vibrate a little bit when changing
directions and it sort of feels like it
adds a bit of a texture with certain
tools
but nevertheless it really works well
with this laptop it's got the shortcut
button it's got the side button and
whenever you're done using it you can
just snap it underneath the front lip of
the laptop where it charges and lives
with a very strong magnet you basically
just you slide the pen in upside down
and it is strong and it's not going
anywhere you kind of have to peel it
back off now here's the fun part if you
do slide it in the wrong way
uh right side up
it kind of misses the laptop but then
all you got to do is
just lift it up and it
snaps into place it's very satisfying so
look there's going to be a ton of new
windows 11 machines laptops coming out
over the next weeks and months and
they're all going to have different
focuses some will have much better
performance than this one some will have
better screens some will have more ports
of course but the theoretical advantage
to the surface one is support
this design and the pen
windows 11 has treated me pretty well
for a couple days with the new start
menu and the new animations and window
controls for multitasking i like those a
lot also i noticed the touch targets get
slightly larger and a little further
apart when it detects that you're going
out of laptop mode
but it's also got a lot of weird quirks
and missing ui features i would highly
recommend watching the verge's full
windows 11 review video on their channel
i'll link it below since i generally
don't do desktop os reviews but yeah
they cover a lot of stuff and you know
as windows 11 improves this whole laptop
will too so i didn't get this laptop
expecting to recommend it to most people
it's obviously for a smaller group
who'll find this easel thing useful or
who will find this pen useful but i'm
also i'm glad it exists like where else
are you going to find a laptop
with a design like this
with a double decker layer to it like
this with this cool hinge it's just a
lot of cool stuff going on so that's
been it thanks for watching and
definitely get subscribed here if you
haven't already to be among the first to
see
what is coming up you're not gonna want
to miss it
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this laptop
hey what's up mkbhd here and this laptop
oh it didn't and this laptop
and this laptop
is trying to be and this laptop
and this laptop
hey what's up mkbhd here and this laptop